okay so let's just discuss what's going
on in Sweden right now so you're
basically saying the borders are pretty
much closed at the moment so what what
are the actual numbers right now so how
many people came in over the last five
Oh
so the actual number it shifts a lot so
let me give you the numbers and her
annual basis yeah
between 1980s and 2010 Sweden took about
twenty five thousand asylum seekers a
year and all not all the silent seekers
stay but on the other hand there is a
family reunification which is very
important that you typically each asylum
seeker nest you an immigrant so let's
just keep that username number that
twenty five thousand a year in 2010 the
Swedish libertarian and the Greens start
to open the borders and there was also
up laxing the borders in the European
level so the number starts to go up two
thousand fourteen eighty or eighty
thousand last year one hundred and sixty
but these 160 almost most of them came
the last three months and those three
months there was about a two month
period and kept going up Sweden was
taking five hundred on an annual basis
five hundred thousand per year Wow
so that would be like if the US had that
that would be like sixteen million a
year asylum seekers and that pressure
desist and that was my four highest in
Europe mm-hmm that pressured the system
so much that even the left green very
very hippie government very very open
borders
they surrendered and they okay we're
going to do a 180 degree shift they
start to impose border controls and
month and a half late their monthly so
it's just start to go immediately and
the people who say the poor are cooking
and I knew it was whether they day
before they impose the border controls
was the record it starts falling now
it's followed by 95 percent and you will
still have people just like completely
denying reality border controls do not
work all research shows you can't talk
to them anyway now it's back to about
25,000 a year and the only reason is
that high it's because they're not doing
it full fully they don't have border
controls everywhere they don't have visa
requirements like Finland imposed so now
it's it's not low but it's manageable
and it's no longer sort of risking the
long-term viability of the welfare state
right okay so now that that basically is
under control let's talk a little bit
about the integration because that's the
part of this that every one of these
countries is dealing with that it seems
to be that the the immigrants are the
migrants or whatever we're calling them
a moment there's a major integration
problem no matter how much you guys give
them that these people be either because
of religion or culture or some
combination thereof or partly because of
Swedish society or any of these European
societies that these people are not
integrating properly so what what's that
act right now where is that yeah so
that's of course very important and when
Sweden had immigration from mostly
European countries and strong
integration immigration was in fact a
net surplus in like in the nineteen
sixties and seventies it was served it
immigrants worked more than Suites and
now of course it's not the other way
around and okay let me first give you
numbers of non-european immigrants of
Swedish origin eighty-five percent work
non-european immigrants fifty-two
percent work and the average income is
lower the share who do not finish
they're not qualify to high school is
something like let's say the Sheryl do
not cry
from high school is about 20% among
Swedes about almost 40% among the 35
folks in the mind a non-european
immigrants now I'm talking about st.
generation right yes but that is that
partially because of language stuff or
second generation yeah
oh four not four super of course not for
second generation and then it's like
fifty sixty percent don't finish high
school you know
now you mentioned some reasons and I
think they're also important the
cultural clash religion the welfare
state so but I think that that there is
actually one fundamental reason to this
which is none of those above its skill
level and my simplified view is that
it's mostly about skill highly-skilled
immigrants integrate low skill do not
let me just give you the numbers because
the numbers are staggering here and
they're often denied so of the asylum
seekers something half have not high
school degrees of these thirty 33
percent don't even have nine years of
schooling a lot of them are illiterate
although student refused to measure how
many something like twenty thirty
percent based on other countries and the
local governments who are illiterate of
the women who are family reunification
have never worked in the home country
and Sweden is an extremely as North
Germany and these countries they're very
skill intensive and increasingly skill
intensive on the other hand where you
have high-skilled immigrants and the
ones who converge in scale like sweet
immigrants who get Swedish education
there are very small differences in
labor market outcomes you know you
cannot detect any major problem with the
discrimination among once you have good
adjustments for skilled of course you
don't have a good skill if you say well
you went to MIT he went to the Mogadishu
Institute of Technology you both have a
degree so then we say you're equally
skilled that's one of ways the people
cheat is like pretending and the people
have this myth or if you've heard it
that well you know
maybe with Iraqis and Afghans and
Somalis but Syria is that's the best
very highly country we are gonna have
problem it's serious I understand have
you heard that's a very common myth boat
in Sweden and Germany and and in Europe
I haven't heard that but it sounds like
the type of myth that people would just
start saying and then go oh that's what
the truth is they know nothing about
Syria Syria is far less insecure than
you are it has it has very little oil it
has it's a peasant economy of Syrian
according the World Bank of the Syrian
population 4% at four-year college
degrees before the war how can you and
then 3 50 percent of population left
right how can you how can you think that
a country where 4% have college degrees
a typical immigrant aren't going to be
college degrees I mean at some point
you're gonna exhaust that even if all of
them come Randy's the made a manipulate
people like III switch government prime
minister we always say their speeches
about the Syrian doctor the students go
hey don't worry
and I finally forced the labor
authorities to give D refused I had to
set up an email and cite law openness of
information acted for how many doctors
have come 41 at that point Wow 41 and I
made a joke that was the order those are
more than the number of times the Prime
Minister mentioned the doctors speech I
mean I just they were so few that the
Labor Minister could have validated
education herself individually so we
don't have to have this data fake debate
pretending that the problem is that they
have degrees but the progress is so late
of it's done anyway so then you have
countries in particularly you have very
very strong correlation between the
countries were immigrants assimilate and
the gap in scale between the natives and
the immigrants the correlation is very
strong you do individual level even
stronger so it's not that Canada and
Australia and to some extent the u.s. or
Switzerland have this magic of
integration it's that they're picking
the highly-skilled immigrants right
Austrian has the highest share stream is
not doing that much worse a little worse
but not touch much worse once you adjust
for country
origin and the education level then
shouldn't Canada no country have for
example it has a high among Somalis
because that's a very uneducated group
the country of course not thought the
country broke down in 1990 a lot of
illiterate
um the US have Somalis don't work and
people who say the u.s. we have this
secret sauce we can integrate all
immigrants they're lying they just heard
a Harvard professor I was in Cambridge
she's saying yes this integration is
great my Harvard class you have all come
from everywhere and the writer so good
okay but what you know I mean do I have
to articulate this right I got it fair
Harvard class right look at the data
Harvard's not just letting anyone in I
think is your point so if you look at
the numbers they're pretty consistent
Turkey Germany Sweden Norway Denmark ten
percent of Syrians roughly have college
degrees about forty fifty percent are
pre high school and those the second
that's the first group the Roman college
degrees most to integrate historical
experience not all because we also have
language problem even if you're well
educated you like my father for example
he was too old to learn language me is
that is a very competitive switch
company that's now we have technology we
have globalization it's just becoming
more and more competitive every year
what interest we have hiring somebody
who doesn't know how to speak Swedish
right and it's 53 years old let's say or
for you and then you but most of the
ones that come young and educated take
find jobs and they do fine there are the
ones are low-skilled so those jobs are
gone and they ain't coming back yeah so
what I find fascinating about this is
that you are really taking this from
your area of expertise which is
economics you're talking about this what
the system can hold
you're giving me actual numbers of
people coming in and what we can pay for
and all of that stuff and yet so much of
this conversation has been couched
around racism or you know the made-up
word of Islamophobia and all that and a
few people that told me to talk to you
said that you might not even be willing
to talk to me because the climate around
that
is so toxic so I don't I think you were
a serious person I researched you but I
knew who you were roughly by research to
see this but I don't talk to people who
have who are racist I look
of course racism exists it's not
completely made up it's like a Red Scare
there were communists in the 50s it's
not a myth Sweden has had more than 20
racist murders the last generation
Norway had brave ik the biggest mass
shooter in human history and you do have
a small number of races even in the u.s.
I mean there not many but you have that
we can go on the internet you find them
or right now the KKK doesn't really
exist but there are people who sit in
their basement and pretend to be they
sympathize with those ideas right and
that's and then the a lot of this nuff
nuttiness of the left and libertarians
is a overreaction to racism and this is
my very very simplified explanation is
that once you removed Christianity and
religion people did not have a moral
grounding that replaced it with
something and we have gone sort of
evolution instead of worshipping God's
people worship ideas mm-hmm and the idea
that morally appeals to them was anti
racism they want this or want to be
saving private ryan' they want to be the
guys to stop Hitler right that's a great
fantasy and that's pure evil and they
can't find Hitler maybe if they could
find Hitler if they go to some
third-world country they don't want to
do that they want to find Hitler close
at home and you know use that to gain
power for themselves you have to create
this powerful enemy so then they take
this small number of genuine racists
that do exist aren't on the number let's
say five ten percent and a causing
problem for immigrants and do genuinely
hate immigrants for no rational reason
they're exaggerating that too absurd
levels yeah I'll give you a number in
Sweden we have a survey which is what
are you most concerned about a serious
scientific survey number one was climate
change very low number two is new Nazis
49% of Suites said they're very
concerned about new Nazis how many new
Nazis are you could probably put them
all in a big group but the media if you
google this Nazism is rising you know
they'll find these three guys who like
to dress
and then they give them all this
attention and it's exactly like this
kind of like ideas of how you manipulate
in a propaganda right Goldstein whatever
or threat scare you use that you know
it's 1984 there uses the manual yeah we
see it coming to life so really what
you're saying is Sweden has almost a
reverse racism problem because the
second thing that they're talking about
is we're afraid of neo-nazis meaning or
new Nazis meaning we're afraid that a
movement is gonna rise up that really is
gonna be racist we're not concerned
about the racism that we see in the
society because there probably is not
that much I mean this is a country that
has tried to do good for the immigrants
yes that's true now let me also be try
to go a little deeper there but I
haven't really articulated let me try to
go look then there is this that there is
soft race that's racism it's not maybe
the right word but let's call it
something you could call soft racism or
soft bigotry or whatever you are calling
this soft discrimination perhaps would
be a better word mm-hmm where Swedes are
and not only Suites you know British
Americans Fred Meyer they have a culture
crock they don't necessarily want to
socialize with immigrants and they look
down on immigrants especially once you
have a system where you mainly take on
skilled people and a lot of them don't
work right that create suppose you call
comments called statistical
discrimination which if you see it talk
her person on average that person is
going to be less educated okay then so
that's become a self-fulfilling prophecy
right an immigrant see this and they see
that by a way there is not a lot of
legitimacy for immigration Swedes never
said ever we want lots of immigrants
there has never been one poll anonymous
poll where they say it's a good idea to
take fewer refugees was was not the
priority and even never said let's make
sure the majority non non-white no they
never said that all right so what they
said is oh we don't want to be racist
and our immigration policy is just about
you it's very small numbers it's just
about humanism because Hitler because
our
then you have all these people see where
what's going on my hometown is changing
my schools are changing I never asked
for this
right it was never it was the people so
people they still vote for this policy
but in an individual level there's a
hypocrisy they do mistreat or are
distant women as they move they don't
worry school with them and immigrants
look at it from their point of view
right so you know they sit on home icy
streets as you say this altruism
signaling welcomed refugees come here
okay they want us let's go there so they
come down they say Oh nobody wants to
hire join me nowhere once it's been the
boss nobody even the least leftist or
greens or libertarians
they never talk to me there is a very
interesting survey that 80% of ethnic
swedes rarely or never socialize with
non-european immigrants have a and this
is by the way partially because this is
a very shy cold society and always been
they almost never talk to people from
hundred years ago if they come from a
different village you know they were
like who is this stranger coming from
two miles away and you know Swedes and
the reasons or the people are most
likely not to know the name of their
neighbor so you get these leftist
basically you get these leftist saying
come on come on come on and then once
they're there they're like that you
don't even have to see you I don't what
the Liberals do in DC do is send their
kids to the black schools they don't do
that they sent the private school and
and if you ask them why they will never
admit it those are not good schools try
ask them why not good school yeah what
do you mean by this it's very critical I
think they should all of them by the way
center kid you should I completely
support having quotas in schools and you
force them everybody has to have equal
racial there was interesting earlier
button New York talked about is usually
cool shares roughly in schools don't
allow this elite and also the rich
elites to destroy society or you know or
destroy social cohesion for everybody
else but then they move yeah Manhattan
is becoming more white it's not becoming
more diverse mmm-hmm and the same thing
in student is that you have a central
part of stock on derivative wealthy
areas are white
Piero's you don't see crime it's not
everybody is either white or their
relative with after it immigrants then
you go fifteen minutes away you get to
huge speed rinkeby it looks like the
jokes the woman says I feel at home here
it's just like Baghdad right right so so
what do what do you guys do or what it's
hard to gauge I guess how much actual
violence you know we see these stories I
see stories in Daily Mail all the time
or independent or wherever we get
nothing in American media about migrants
or immigrants that are raping women or
that the crime rates are really high now
I guess your initial answer to that
would be well this is really an economic
issue but how do you sell how do you
separate that from some of the cultural
and religious stuff that comes with the
interacts obviously and you know for
example if you observe that the group
has low income and then you observe that
this group has low high crime it's not a
scientifically correct analysis that
poverty is causing crime because it
could be that you have a third factor
let's say lack of skill more let's say a
bad culture or culture is not adapted to
modernity it's causing both you to
behave poorly not get education we don't
have don't follow the norms right and
then you're both in the poor and high
crime so it does exist it all interacts
because then if you have poverty that's
good probably reinforce this this is a
very complex of sociological problem we
don't have an answer to it but before I
say that let me because I've got to come
back to finish my point about the
immigrant even point of view is
important for you guys in the u.s. to
design as well as I'm there right in
Europe that immigration restriction is
I'm not going say your blame in this
it's not a little moral blame but less
of a more constructive view which is why
do so many people emphasize with these
ideas and why do the immigrants resent
this the whole society yeah well because
from the point of view of the immigrants
you can say well sweets don't really
discriminate you if you get a job and so
on it's true I'm not really been
discriminating student I've never know
whatever market
never however immigrants don't feel
right they fee they see that sweet
people are looking down on them they see
that both the left and the right all of
them didn't want to leave it as I say
they waited maybe they grow up and you
look around them and I said oh wait a
second
everybody in my neighborhood has a hair
color I have is poor and everybody who
has blonde or blue-eyed isn't affluent
what's going on here well then somebody
comes a demagogue and says it's
capitalism or it's which racism it's
very very understandable at the human
level and you say why do they burn cars
and I always use this answer which is
this and you said this this is about
economics no it's not let me say my
answer isn't about to City this who is
the father of international relations in
the Peloponnesian War it says there are
three main motivation for human conflict
which is fear interest honor
don't forget honor right people feel
this they feel that society is pissing
on them they don't get respect if you
ask their why you're doing this they
usually say something here they say the
police attacked me you know which is
well perhaps try stop committing crime
maybe the police will not attack you
know they say that retaliated but very
often they say I want respect some
version of that well at some level they
have a point they're not getting respect
they never chose by the way you write
these kids most of them they usually are
born they're commas kids don't really
choose that and at the structural level
I think it's not constructive to sit
around and say you have to take
individual responsibility responsibility
belongs to leaders of the country
intellectual leaders the politicians the
media those are the people who should
think about this structurally and solve
it and among the right they should be a
little more understanding about two
issues one is the real racism exists and
there should be more of an attempt to
stamping out not to give the left and
excuse and the immigrants by the way
deeply fear racist because they meet
that I've been attacked by racists
physically many times instrument growing
up and that that's very easy to create
to have the immigrants shift to the left
as a protection and to attack sort of
these - these people are few by
they do legitimize and confirm this
mythology that rate that Hitler is just
around the corner that that average
European is just an inch away from
digging a pit like cloning him and
protect Piccolomini Fuhrer or what is
this thing that they're saying I'm a big
fan of Trump but it's absurd thing Trump
supporters want a dictatorship that just
has nothing to do with reality but
people buy it a lot of people in the
middle or high logic they buy that oh
yeah yes that's just like Hitler and
also usually these people are dumb and
on as you can ignorant they don't know
anything about history
Hitler is what they know what Hitler is
well there was this world war ii and
hitler before that it was something like
a mock germany was not a liberal
democracy at that time it only happened
once in history by the way the people
who fought Hitler by the way those
people if there were life today some of
them are alive but most of them not the
left today would call them fascists Yeah
right the people who storm Normandy
Beach were their values or Patriots they
were maybe somewhat socially
conservative they were not intolerant by
the most but maybe they would not have
supported the idea of open borders or
you know and yeah today there is people
who stop it there would be called
fascist right or neo-cons probably
that's the one that gets thrown around
here all the time yeah yeah sure yeah
well listen there there's so much that
we could unpack and we barely got into
the to the far right which is a response
to some of this stuff so I hope we can
do this again in a few months and I
really appreciate you taking the time
because I know you have a crazy schedule
so I apologize for my connection problem
no no absolutely no problem so I want to
thank dr. Tino's son and dodgy for
joining me tell you what's the best
place that people can find your writing
in English because I found a lot in all
kinds of other languages but give me
where can I send them for English
National Review out with some English
articles great fantastic thank you so
much